[Musik]
die Malaria wütete es war furchtbar die
alten und Kinder starben an Krankheiten
und Hunger
viele Eltern ließen die Leichname ihre
Kinder einfach im Wald liegen
[Musik]
Hauptstadt
Äthiopiens
Menschenmassen versammeln sich an
Epiphanias
er ist nur einer von vielen Zuschauern
doch erhole Mela weiß dass die große
Mehrheit der feiernden bei der Rückkehr
in ihre Dörfer Armut und Leid vorfinden
wird
er glaubt die reichen Länder hätten in
Afrika versagt die Zeit sei reif für
Veränderung
ob die reichen Länder wohl wenn sie
Afrika nicht länger belächeln würden
erkennen könnten dass die Bewohner
Afrikas den Kontinent selbst aus der
Armut befreien würden
hunderten Milliarden Dollar an Spenden
und Tausender Hilfsarbeiter zum Trotz
hat sich die Lage verschlimmert
nicht die Korruption afrikanischer
Regierungen wirft den Industrieländern
jedoch vor dass Ihre Hilfe nicht die
richtigen Menschen erreiche ich weiß
nicht wie viel Geld nach Äthiopien ging
die Rede ist von Milliarden also halte
ich es für fair auszurechnen wie viel
davon am Ziel ankam
das Geld floss in verschiedene Zwecke
hochbezahlte Helfer aus anderen Ländern
ginge das Geld direkt an die Bauern
könnte das ihr Leben verändern
er verlor früh seinen Vater seine Mutter
konnte kaum seine Bildung finanzieren
wir hatten einen kleinen Hof
Zitat ihr Bestes
um mich zu erziehen
es war schwer darum war sie so
wundervoll
es war nicht einfach damals
du ohne Vater aufzuwachsen
er fehlte mir als Vorbild ich oder bei
dem Modell
je älter er wurde desto mehr frustrierte
in die Stagnation in der Äthiopien
jahrzehntelang blieb das Leid seiner
Landsleute stets unverändert
er sieht einen Großteil der Schuld bei
ausländischen Behörden
entwicklungsbehörden sagen gerne was zu
tun ist
anstatt mit den Menschen zu arbeiten
wer zwingen sie ihnen ihre Denkweisen
und Ansätze auf
Verona
das kann nicht funktionieren
hinterfragte die Logik dahinter in
Gebieten ohne Gesundheitsversorgung eine
Schule zu bauen wo die Kinder zu krank
oder zu hungrig waren um sie zu besuchen
wofür die Saatgut spenden wenn die
fruchtbare Erde weggespült wurde
ihm zufolge sollten Außenstehende die
Afrikas Bedürfnisse nicht verstehen
nicht länger Lösungen aufzwingen sondern
die Menschen fragen was sie ihrer
Meinung nach brauchen
von der Außenwelt unbemerkt startete er
vor fünf Jahren ein riesiges Experiment
in Sodo in der Mitte Äthiopiens
das Gebiet im großen afrikanischen
Grabenbruch wird von Hungersnöten
heimgesucht hier wollte er eine
Viertelmillion Menschen überzeugen
kostenlose Hilfe abzulehnen und sich
einen eigenen Weg aus der Armut zu
erarbeiten
er nennt es self help wir geben nichts
umsonst her Geschenke schaffen
Abhängigkeit
unserer Philosophie zufolge muss man
sich selbst helfen wenn man will dass
einem geholfen wird
das ist entscheidend
sein Plan war einfach 20 Menschen neue
Fähigkeiten Lehren die dann ihrerseits
20 weitere Anhänger ausbilden die
wiederum 20 Anhänger ausbilden immer
weiter mittlerweile hat er zehntausende
Anhänger
[Musik]
unsere Kameras haben das Experiment die
letzten zwei Jahre begleitet
[Musik]
wir folgen den Geschichten von Amine
andele MOLOGEN
die dort um Erfolg Ringen wo früher
Regenerationen scheiterten
andere sind ebenso entschlossen das
Experiment zu zerstören um ihre
Interessen zu schützen
maneland Geldverleiher die ihr Geld auf
Kosten der Armen verdienen sehen ihr
Geschäft in Gefahr
für mich ist das Spiel aus ich habe kaum
noch Kunden
die beschlagen die wenigen verbleibenden
Bäume
Bauern stehen ihren Nachbarn Wasser
dazu kommt die Rebellion einer
verheerten Region in der die Männer
nicht ohne kostenlose Verpflegung
arbeiten wollen ohne die Hilfen sterben
wir
kann awole Mehler eine Gemeinschaft die
seit mehr als einem halben Jahrhundert
von ausländischer Hilfe abhängt von der
Veränderung überzeugen für einen
Bruchteil der Kosten und ohne Hilfe
ausländische Entwicklungshelfer
[Musik]
entgegen der häufigen Darstellung sind
weite Teile Äthiopiens fruchtbar
insbesondere zur Regenzeit
das Land sollte normalerweise genug
Nahrung für seine Bevölkerung
produzieren können
die Dürre ist niemals fern
die Ernte geht ein Nutztiere verenden
der Hunger kehrt zurück
wie viele insodo haben wohl Familie
Mitglieder an Krankheit und Hunger
verloren
[Musik]
alle von euch
der Hauptgrund der Hungersnöte ist die
Abhängigkeit von einer Pflanzenart Mais
ohne Mais sind alle in Gefahr
abulle Giso ist ein Musterbeispiel sein
Leben ist beschwerlich doch bei einer
Dürre würde seine Familie monatelang
Hunger leiden
wir essen morgens mittags und abends
Brot
im Winter geht auch das nicht
dann müssen wir weniger essen Wasser
bekommen wir nur durch Regen ohne Regen
gibt es keine Mais
als erstes musste er wohl mehr und sein
Team der Bedrohung durch Hungersnot
begegnen die Lösung war eine einzige
erstaunliche Pflanze
in Äthiopien heißt enzete die magische
Pflanze
[Musik]
es ist eine der vielseitigsten Pflanzen
alles ist verwirkbar
[Musik]
früher wuchs sie nur im Gebirge self
help führte eine Hybridform für das
Flachland ein
sie benötigt kaum Wasser und kann zu
Brot Klößen und Brei verarbeitet werden
aus den Blättern kann man Seile
herstellen
[Musik]
am wichtigsten ist jedoch ihre
Haltbarkeit sie kann hier sieben Jahre
lang vergraben bleiben ohne zu verderben
so ein Paket ernährt eine sechsköpfige
Familie einen Monat lang bei Dürre
werden Sie ausgegraben und sind nach wie
vor essbar
sie gehörten zu den ersten Anhängern sie
lernten in Sete anzubauen um dem
Hungertod zu entgehen
sie wiederum lehrten ihre Anhänger heute
ist die Pflanze in der ganzen Region
verbreitet
[Musik]
überleben war das eine doch um die
Wirtschaft zu verändern mussten die
Bauern mehr Nahrung als sie für ihre
Familien benötigten und zudem
einträgliche Pflanzen anbauen
um Pflanzen
es war mein Hobby
bist
dann würde ich Landwirt und wollte mehr
erreichen
die Samen hier in der Region waren
allerdings nicht wirklich zu gebrauchen
lernte als einer der ersten wie man eine
Gärtnerei anlegt bei ihm entstand eine
Mischung aus Paprika Zwiebeln und Kaffee
die er nun an Nachbarn verkauft
durch die Ausbildung sammelte ich viele
Erfahrungen
sein Wissen zu teilen gehört für
mologeta zum Geschäft
je mehr Bauern der ausbildet desto mehr
kaufen seine Setzlinge
wir zerschneiden das Plastik dann
drücken wir ein wenig Erdreich wieder
zurück in das Loch
danach sorgen wir wieder für ebenen
Boden
das Leben war früher hart wir hatten
nichts unsere Kinder konnten mir nicht
in die Schule schicken
wir könnten keine Schulbücher kaufen
genau
der hat nicht mal genug Geld um auf den
Markt zu gehen stimmt
das verändert sich jetzt doch nicht so
wie man es hier erwartet hätte
bis vor kurzem war Sado wie fast alle
anderen Gebiete vollkommen von Männern
dominiert
durch einen auf dem Kontinent einmaligen
Rollentausch kontrollieren jetzt die
Frauen das Haushaltseinkommen
es wurde ein spar- und Kreditprogramm
eine miniaturbank erschaffen und nur
Frauen dürfen Geld leihen
Männer sind wohl nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig
männer und Frauen sind nicht gleich
wir verschwenden kein Geld sondern
investieren es zu Hause
Männer betrinken sich nur sinnlos
von meinem ersten Darlehen kaufte und
züchtete ich Rinder
dann zahl ich es zurück vom zweiten
Darlehen eröffnete ich das Restaurant
meine Kinder gehen in die Schule
als MOLOGEN die Idee für ein Restaurant
auf dem Land hatte hielt man sie für
verrückt
dadurch das Experiment hier jedoch die
Einkommen steigen scheint es zu
funktionieren und sehr gut Frauen können
Geld besser verwalten als Männer
wir strengen uns zu Hause an und sind
erfolgreich beim Verkauf auf dem Markt
wir verdienen anständig bei dem
tausende Frauen machen mit
sie leihen Geld mit geringen Zinsen und
kaufen Schafe Rinder oder Saatgut für
ihre Männer die Bauern
mit dem Gewinn begleichen Sie die
Schulden und leihen sich mehr um ihre
Geschäfte auszuweiten
wenn es jedoch nach dem örtlichen
Geldverleiher tadele ficardo ginge
hätten sie nie anfangen sollen
ich gab ihnen einen Vertrag und dann am
Ende des Jahres verlangte ich
schließlich mein Geld zurück
wenn jemand nicht zahlen konnte kam
derjenige im vor Gericht
bevor die Nichtregierungsorganisation
ankam konnte ich 100% Zinsen verlangen
das ist jetzt vorbei
amare Studio damals eine der ersten am
Experiment teil nun lehrt sie ihre
Anhänger für sich selbst einzutreten
ich habe viel für meine Familie und mich
bewirkt
vorher kannten wir unsere Rechte nicht
durch die Treffen wissen wir nun
Bescheid jetzt wissen wir wie wir Geld
leihen und uns vor der Unterdrückung
durch die Männer befreien können
ich habe sie vieles gelehrt von der
modernen rinder- und Hühnerhaltung bis
zum Anbau von Gemüse Papayas und Mangos
[Musik]
terne Bienenstöcke baut
der Honig ist gut
[Musik]
jeder Bienenstock gibt 40 Kilogramm
obwohl amaritsch keine formelle Bildung
genoss reißt sie in die Stadt um neue
Mittel für die Frauenkooperative
auszuhandeln
noch vor ein paar Jahren wäre das
undenkbar gewesen
[Musik]
amaritsch hat eine tolle Persönlichkeit
sie ist erstaunlich
waren die meisten Frauen Scheu
doch diese Schüchternheit schwand
langsam
Chancen
ein besseres Ziel gibt es nicht
sie ist schlau und wir haben ähnliche
Ansichten
sie ermöglicht unseren Kindern einen
guten Start ins Leben alles was sie tut
ist durchdacht
was wollt ihr einmal werden Ärztin
ja helft ihr mir
Lehrerin du bist Lehrerin werden ja
und du lemlem
Pilotin Pilotin ja fantastisch ihr seid
die besten
Familienplanung ist ein wichtiger Teil
des Experiments zum ersten Mal seit
langem fällt die Geburtenrate in der
Region
ihre Ziele zu erreichen müssen die
Kinder von amaritsch die Region jedoch
verlassen
es gibt in der Gegend nur eine
Grundschule die weiterführende Schule
ist 30 Kilometer entfernt nur wenige
Eltern können sich das leisten
die Menschen hier sammeln Geld für eine
eigene Schule doch noch ist das ein
Traum
die Fläche für den Bau wurde schon
reserviert aber die Schule muss noch
warten
[Musik]
im Hochnebel auf einem Berg in der
Region versammeln sich die Gläubigen zum
Morgengebet
[Musik]
als der Nebel sich lüftet erblicken wir
eine der verwüsteten Regionen Äthiopiens
[Musik]
das ist die sodo-region auch
Wasserscheide genannt
in der Regenzeit strömen große Mengen
wertvollen Regenwassers von den Bergen
herab und spülen den Mutterboden davon
um letztlich ungenutzt in einem Fluss zu
wenden
[Musik]
das Gebiet mit einst üppiger Vegetation
ist heute beinahe eine Wüste mehr als
10.000 Menschen sind von einem einzigen
brunnenabhängig das Wasser muss aus
mindestens 300 Metern Tiefe hochgepumpt
werden
das Gebiet war einst dicht bewaldet mit
der Zeit verschwanden die Bäume
der Mutterboden für den Anbau von
Pflanzen unerlässlich war der Erosion
ausgesetzt und die Bauern konnten keine
Nahrung mehr anbauen
something has to change es muss sich
etwas ändern erhole Mehler ist überzeugt
dass die Bauern es selbst schaffen
müssen
sie kommen aus der ganzen Region
zusammen um den Strom des Wassers
aufzuhalten damit es anschließend
versickert
nur so können Sie den Grundwasserspiegel
in erreichbare Nähe bringen
wie ihr wisst wurde das Land in der
Region völlig verwüstet
wir müssen daher alle zusammenarbeiten
um es wiederherzustellen
zuerst möchte ich Euch allen danken dass
ihr heute hier seid noch dazu weil ihr
aus eigenem Antrieb gekommen seid
[Applaus]
Vertreter an der Wasserscheide
das Gebiet wird von wiederkehrenden
Fluten und Bodenerosion heimgesucht wir
müssen dem Prozess aufhalten
physische und biologische Bewahrung ist
hierbei der Schlüssel
auf der physischen Seite verhindern wir
die Überflutung indem wir Gräben und
Stufen errichten
und so verhindern wir dass die
Wasserströme das Erdreich abtragen
auf biologischer Seite bedecken wir das
Land mit Bäumen
die Bauern hier Pflanzen Setzlinge
die wir hier ergreifen sollen die
Fruchtbarkeit des Bodens verbessern und
die Erosion durch die Überflutung
verhindern
früher gab es für die Arbeit kostenlose
Nahrung von anderen Hilfsorganisationen
ist aber entschlossen die Abhängigkeit
zu beenden
einige Anführer der Bauern sind aber
alles andere als glücklich
ist es beschämend um Hilfe zu bitten
aber wir sind in dieser Lage weil wir
arm sind
wir müssen uns fragen warum wir so hart
arbeiten um das Land der anderen
umzupflügen
wir werden nicht arbeiten sie sollen uns
Weizen geben wie früher
auch für amarit-studio und die anderen
Vertreter des spar- und kreditmodells
läuft es nicht gut
einige Frauen konnten das geliehene Geld
nicht zurückzahlen
das Gremium muss einen Aufschub gewähren
oder sie vor Gericht stellen
tun sie nichts könnte es Nachahmer
inspirieren
warum sind die Schulden nicht beglichen
also eine Gaststätten warum bist du im
Verzug
ich habe daran gearbeitet dass Darlehen
abzubezahlen
meine Kinder haben mit der Schule
angefangen aber mein Haus drohte
anzustürzen
darum habe ich es mit dem Kredit
repariert
Rendite
wir gaben dir den Kredit damit du ein
kleines Unternehmen gründen und dann
Einkommen verbessern könntest
der Kredit war für keinen anderen Zweck
bestimmt wie zum Beispiel den
Wiederaufbau deines Hauses
deine Antwort ist inakzeptabel
[Musik]
das war ein Fehler von ihr das Geld für
ihr Haus zu verwenden
sie muss jetzt die Zahlungen vornehmen
sonst ergreifen wir rechtliche Schritte
die anderen ihre solllichkeit begründen
offenbart sich die Spaltung des Gremiums
meine Geschäfte liefen gut an ich begann
mit den Zahlungen
aber dann wurde mein Kind schwer krank
ich hatte das Geld und musste eine
schwere Entscheidung treffen
ich nutze es also für die
Behandlungskosten meines
kindesi Zeit für eine Entscheidung
das Gremium hat die Situation bewertet
und setzt eine neue Frist
die Schuldner willigen ein bei
verspäteter Zahlung zusätzliche 100 Birr
für Gerichtskosten und 150 Bier an das
Gremium zu entrichten
zugesichert durch Unterschrift
Sie erhalten weitere drei Monate Zeit
halten Sie die Frist nicht ein drohen
gerichtliche folgen sie alle müssen
unterzeichnen
es gibt viele Gründe warum sie das
wenige Geld dass sie haben so streng
überwachen auch abseits der Finanzierung
von Schulen und anderen wichtigen
Projekten
Solomon kedäbe ist seit kurzem Leiter
der neuen Klinik im Ort Keller
sie ist die erste ihrer Art und kümmert
sich um 40.000 Menschen in Sodom
früher mussten diese Patienten 20 km
Laufen und behandelt zu werden
[Musik]
die Gemeinschaft steuert Geld und
Arbeitskräfte bei
den Menschen gefällt es sehr jederzeit
Behandlung bekommen zu können
Sie sehen die Klinik auch als ihre
Klinik
[Musik]
bevor die Klinik entstand war man hier
von arzneimittelverkäufern abhängig die
oft das Zehnfache verlangten
now in ihrer eigenen Apotheke bekommen
Sie sie nun fast ohne Aufpreis
auch das Krankenhaus der Region wurde
von der Bevölkerung selbst errichtet
als self help her kamen trafen sie eine
Vereinbarung mit der Lokalregierung die
Bevölkerung stellt Geld und Arbeit für
den Bau von Schulen und Krankenhäusern
die Behörden Zahlen Personal und
Unterhalt
der Hospital Krankenhaus gab mussten die
Menschen früher 150 Kilometer nach Addis
oder 100 Kilometer nach husana
sie können sich vorstellen dass die
Versorgungslage damals ein großes
Problem war
mehr als eine Million Menschen auch von
außerhalb des sellfeldbereichs können
nun die Anlage nutzen
welcher dieses die schlimmsten
Krankheiten hier sind
Atemwegsinfektionen Tuberkulose
Lungenentzündungen
das Engagement der Gemeinschaft gab uns
die Energie das Krankenhaus zu errichten
das jetzt wiederum der Gemeinschaft
dient
das Krankenhaus funktioniert aber
anderswo läuft nicht alles nach Plan
[Musik]
das Projekt an der Wasserscheide ist in
Gefahr
vor nur 18 Monaten lag der
Grundwasserspiegel 300 Meter unter der
Erde
sie gruben Dämme und Furchen damit das
Regenwasser versickert und das
Grundwasser steigt
das Grundwasser ist auf 30 Meter
gestiegen
mit der Zeit wird das Wasser weiter bis
auf 10 oder 15 Meter steigen denn so
dass es für Bauern einfach zugänglich
wird
du wach
vor Beginn des Projektes bekamen die
Bauern für jede Arbeit kostenlose
Nahrung aus Amerika oder Kanada arbeiten
die meisten Bauern sind damit
einverstanden sie arbeiten hart manche
Bauern aber machen Probleme sagen die
anderen sollten nicht ohne
Nahrungsmittel Lieferungen Arbeiten
der Bauernrat hat ein Treffen einberufen
erhole erscheint mit seinem Team
einige rebellieren sie sind es gewohnt
Weizen für ihre Arbeit zu bekommen du
musst erklären dass das Land zur Wüste
wird und sie antreiben wieder zu
arbeiten
wir arbeiten hier umsonst früher wurden
wir für unsere Arbeit bezahlt jetzt
bekommen wir nichts warum sollten wir
umsonst arbeiten bis das Problem gelöst
ist wenn uns die Organisation Weizen
geben kann wir verweigern die Arbeit
der Anführer der Rebellion Gemba adane
kam nicht zur Versammlung
wir wollen sofort unseren Lohn darum
wollen wir nicht arbeiten ohne diese
Belohnung haben wir kein Interesse
seine Ablehnung ist verständlich
so sehr awohle und sein Team beteuern
das Grundwasser steige in der Einöde um
sein Zuhause kann er nichts davon
erkennen
die Entwicklungshilfe wird uns nicht
ewig ernähren
welche Optionen bleiben uns
wenn wir nicht wollen dass das Land zur
Wüste wird und unsere Kinder leiden
müssen wir die Umwelt ändern
wenn wir nicht umgehend handeln wird das
hier eine Wüste und nichts überlebt
einige Bauern sprechen sich für melas
Plan aus
was passiert wenn der Weizen der
Entwicklungshilfe wegfällt wir werden
sterben
wir können nicht warten und nichts tun
wir müssen arbeiten wir alle
das Treffen endet ohne Ergebnis
[Musik]
den gender adanes Protest sich ausweitet
Gerät das ganze Projekt in Gefahr
[Musik]
es war Amine in dele der sich für den
Verzicht auf Entwicklungshilfe
ausgesprochen hat
sie sind es gewohnt den Weizen geschenkt
zu bekommen dadurch wurden sie abhängig
davon
vor Projektbeginn lebt dich noch nicht
einmal hier
und verdiente drei Birne etwa 30 Cent am
Tag
es war nur ein Tal ohne Straßen
nicht einmal Esel und Rinder konnten
hierher kommen
die sind nur dank der Schutzprojekte
hier
früher konnte man in der Region kaum
Gemüse anbauen wir hatten nur Mais und
Hirse
ist sicher arbeiten die Bauern an der
Wasserscheide zusammen werden sie ebenso
erfolgreich wie andere
in der ganzen Region entstehen
kooperativen
bevor self help ein Bewässerungssystem
installierte lag das Land hier brach
[Musik]
wir verdienen unseren Lebensunterhalt
als Bauern uns geht es jetzt viel besser
als früher
auch unsere Ernährung ist jetzt besser
und gesünder geworden
Kartoffeln Tomaten und Zwiebeln an
und verkaufen sie auf dem Markt
so leben wir
bei jedem Bauern vielleicht 100
Kilogramm Zwiebeln
[Musik]
in der Zentrale von cellfeld mit der
Rebellion an der Wasserscheide befassen
kann beginnt schon die nächste Krise
wir haben ein Problem einige Bauern
stehlen Wasser von anderen Bauern da
müssen wir umgehend einschreiten wenn
wir das Problem nicht lösen führt das zu
weiteren Probleme
die Bewässerungssystem sollte den Ertrag
vieler Bauern maximieren auch in der
Trockenzeit
es hat nicht nur die Landschaft sondern
auch das Leben der Bewohner verändert
ein Mitglied der Kooperative leitet
scheinbar heimlich mehr Wasser auf seine
eigenen Felder
für Außenstehende wirkt es banal aber
hier geht es ums Überleben
wieder einmal muss avole vermitteln
dort wird bewässert jetzt nicht mehr wer
hat es gestohlen er dort ja gehen wir
hin okay los
einige wollen die Polizei rufen andere
werden aggressiv warum spielst du Wasser
meine Zwiebeln verbrennen die anderen
halten sich an den Plan was ist dein
Problem
es gibt einen Zeitplan für das Wasser
ganz ruhig reden wir lieber im Schatten
drüben
warum stehst du Wasser
weil mein Gemüse in der Hitze eingeht
denkst du das geht uns dann anders
was soll ich sonst tun mein Gemüse geht
ein
warte bis du dran bist
die anderen wollen ihn vom bewässerten
Land werfen
die kooperative hat den Menschen hier
leben geschenkt wird jemand rausgeworfen
verliert er alle Privilegien der
Gemeinde Mitglieder und fällt wieder in
die Arme zurück
das ist die schlimmste Strafe für ihn
das hier ist der dreh- und Angelpunkt
die gesamte Region wurde von einzelnen
Unternehmern und Bauern in Kooperativen
verwandelt
das Durchschnittseinkommen hat sich
vervierfacht überall werden exotische
Waren angeboten die man hier zuvor fast
nie sah
hallo
[Musik]
auch ein Steuereintreiber ist gekommen
wer nicht Teil des Projekts ist kann
davon nur träumen
Familie von Wasser und Brot lebt
sie Leben buchstäblich auf der falschen
Straßenseite der Hofmann hat der agav
auf der anderen Straßenseite liegt
gerade noch im Bereich von sellfabe
auch er lebte einst von Wasser und Brot
doch nun baut er Zwiebeln Paprika
Kartoffeln und eine Mischung lukrativer
Pflanzen an dir auf dem Markt verkauft
vom Gewinn ließ er ein Wasserloch in
seinen Feldern errichten damit auch eine
heftige Dürre seine Ernte nicht zerstört
seiner Familie geht es gut seine Kinder
gehen in die Schule
wie Millionen Afrikaner sehnt sich auch
abdulle nach dieser Chance
gebe man mir diese Gelegenheit mein
Leben so zu ändern würde ich es tun
wie er bin ich gesund und stark
self help wird das Projekt bald
ausweiten und abdulle will unbedingt mit
dabei sein
es geht nicht nur um Überleben sondern
auch um stolz
ich will diese Chance wirklich nutzen
hätte ich die gleichen Chancen ginge es
mir jetzt viel besser ich könnte gute
Kleidung tragen
ich habe große Hoffnungen ich will ein
Haus bauen und meiner Familie neue
Kleidung kaufen können
ich könnte Ochsen auf dem Hof nutzen
meiner Familie besseres Essen und mehr
Sauberkeit ermöglichen
im Gegensatz dazu konnte amarit Studio
den Gewinn den sie mit ihrer Ernte
erzielt hat für den Bau eines Brunnens
in Ihrem Garten nutzen
voller Stolz zeigt sie in ihren 20
Anhängern
in Krankheiten verursacht von schlechten
Wasser und das nicht sauber war
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir sie alle überwunden und
müssen uns weniger oft in ärztliche
Behandlung begeben
[Musik]
auch das Restaurant der higlos erlebt
Veränderungen
das neue Dach ist fertig neue Möbel sind
bestellt und der für die Region übliche
Lehmboden wird durch festen Zement
ersetzt
[Musik]
a hat sich das Leben völlig gewandelt
dieses Paar wartet stets geduldig auf
große Ereignisse
weißt du noch wie du lange nach unserer
Hochzeit dein erstes Kind bekommen hast
ja das war vor sieben Jahren
Kosten zuerst kam merit
dann vier kinderlose Jahre und dann
Elias
aber Du bist glücklich ja ja
unser Leben ist jetzt viel besser
sie sind ein großartiges Ehepaar
wirklich sie sind ein leuchtendes
Beispiel für die Gemeinde die ihren Weg
aus der Armut verfolgen konnte
sie haben gezeigt dass man aus der Armut
ausbrechen kann wenn man hart daran
arbeitet
auch die Kinder der Region haben Grund
zur Freude
heute ist ein stolzer Tag für die
Menschen in Sodom
[Applaus]
tausende sind gekommen denn endlich
wurde genug Geld gesammelt um den
Grundstein für ein besonderes Gebäude zu
legen
der Bau der weiterführenden Schule
beginnt
mehr als drei Jahre lang sammelten sie
Geld durch den Verkauf ihrer Ernte die
kleiderherstellung und direkte Spenden
der Bewohner
sie selbst haben es vollbracht nun sehen
sie endlich die Früchte ihrer Arbeit
mein gutes was für ein großartiger Tag
für uns alle
gekommen sind
[Musik]
aber nicht alle haben Grund zu feiern
nach drei Monaten konnten zwei der sechs
Frauen ihre Schulden bei der
Frauenkooperative nicht innerhalb der
neuen Frist begleichen
[Musik]
eröffnete mit dem geliehenen Geld ein
Restaurant um ihre Kinder zu versorgen
von denen eines eine Behinderung hat
meine Frist ist abgelaufen
mein Mann hat eine zweite Familie
er ist Oberhaupt zweier Haushalte das
ist schwer für ihn dann kann man
finanziell darum nur wenig helfen
verkaufte erfolgreich waren auf dem
Markt bevor ihr Mann sie und ihre Kinder
nach einem Streit aus dem Haus warf
ich war ein Jahr lang obdachlos
konnte meine Kinder nicht ernähren
dafür nutzte ich den Kredit bis das Geld
weg war
ich habe nichts mehr niemand ernährt
meine Kinder oder zahlt für ihre
Ausbildung
ihr wurdet vor das schuldengremium
Berufen
bei unserem letzten Treffen sagtet ihr
ihr würdet die Schulden begleichen
das habt Ihr hier so unterschrieben
andere würden nicht bezahlen wenn das
Gremium nicht hart bleibt
wenn sie das Geld haben ist alles gut
wenn nicht
sollten wir vor Gericht gehen
um das Geld zurückzubekommen
rechtliche Schritte ihre Kinder müssen
womöglich aus der Schule und landen auf
der Straße
denn man einigt sich dann auf einen
letzten Kompromiss sie bekommen noch
zwei Monate aber nur wenn Sie einen
weiteren Garantiegeber für ihre Schulden
finden
ich freue mich sehr darüber
ich möchte der Vereinigung von Herzen
für ihr Verständnis mir gegenüber danken
[Musik]
an der Wasserscheide trägt die vor der
Rebellion getane Arbeit Früchte überall
im Flachland entsteht grüne Vegetation
[Musik]
abole Mela versucht unermüdlich die
Bauern zurückzugewinnen
er bemerkt dass die regelsführer nicht
gekommen sind
die Anwesenden hingegen wirken
entschlossen auch ohne sie
weiterzumachen
ich hätte wegen wichtiger Geschäfte
weggemußt aber dieses Treffen konnte ich
nicht verpassen ich sehe gewaltigen
Fortschritt insbesondere in der Rückkehr
der grünen Flecken
betont noch einmal dass die Zukunft
allein in ihren Händen liegt
wenn ihr nicht zusammenarbeitet werden
das Land und der Boden wieder weggespült
wenn wir das nicht aufhalten wird die
Gegend zu einer vollkommenen Wüste und
absolut unbrauchbar dann könnt ihr hier
nicht mehr leben
oder die regelsführer Schweigen doch
hunderte sind gekommen um die nächsten
Gräben gegen die Fluten auszuheben
denn dann erklimmen und vermittelt cemba
adane und die anderen Mächte gern
Rebellenführer den Hang und sie haben
Ihr Werkzeug mitgebracht
ich habe erkannt dass die schädlichen
Auswirkungen hier uns alle in die Armut
getrieben haben um meiner Gemeinde zu
helfen muss ich an mir selbst arbeiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ohne einen einzigen Entwicklungshelfer
und für einen Bruchteil der Kosten eines
vergleichbar umfangreichen Projekts
ergreifen nahezu eine viertel Millionen
Menschen in Afrika die Gelegenheit beim
Schopf sich aus der extremen Armut zu
befreien
die Märkte Quellen vor waren über und
eine neue Unternehmergeneration baut auf
die Zukunft
[Musik]
neu entstandene Schulen geben den
jüngsten höhere Ziele
Kliniken verbessern das Gesundheitswesen
der Region
selbst der Hunger ist dank der
Einführung einer nahezu magischen
Pflanze viel weniger bedrohlich
Afrikaner helfen Afrikanern
Nachbarn helfen Nachbarn
die Menschen sind voller Stolz ihr
Schicksal wieder selbst in die Hand zu
nehmen
jetzt jenseits der Grenzen von zellfällt
jedoch ist die Armut weiter unübersehbar
[Musik]
die Menschen hier fragen sich
was wird aus uns
[Musik]
Afrika kann seine Probleme selbst lösen
[Applaus]
[Musik]